well as we know valentine's day is just
a few days away it's coming up on sunday
because of the pandemic a lot of couples
might be celebrating at home this year
bianca holman joins us live at the smith
center with their virtual valentine's
day performance that you can check out
good morning bianca
tell us more about it
hey good morning sherry you know it's
been almost a year
since there have been an audience and
folks sitting in these seats here at the
smith center but
no worries because even though this
theater has been black they've been
busy i'm joined here by president and
ceo
myron and so tell us what have you all
been up to because i know it's been dark
here inside but
you all still have been quite busy we
have been busy getting ready for the day
that we can reopen
uh we're doing all kinds of things to
make sure that
the day that we reopen we do so safely
so we're disinfecting and buying
equipment to make sure that
that everybody will be safe when we come
back to the smith center
and we're doing lots of virtual
programming and doing things online as
well
yeah so i know you have educational
programming for the kids they've been
attending new matinees
what do you have planned for this month
this month of love
couples and spouses they're looking for
dates yeah oh well listen
a great date night dave cause and brian
mcknight are coming together on
valentine's day eve okay and they're
doing a great concert for us
there are a number of shows coming up
this week and
in in the coming weeks that celebrate
the stuff that we love to do here live
at the smith center for sure you all are
again
the hub of culture and arts here in our
town and i understand
you're a non-profit so it's so critical
that the community
shows their support for everything that
you do well i appreciate you saying that
you know in the
in the year or so that we've been closed
we've lost
37 million dollars in ticket sales
we have no revenue coming in except for
those
gifts that people are sending our way so
there's a
there's a campaign to sustain the smith
center there's a reopening
fund and we love it when people go
online and they make a five dollar or
twenty dollar or
thousand dollar donation to make sure
that we're ready
uh to reopen when the time comes perfect
and i understand of course we got the
valentine's day event as well but also
you have some black history programming
so
tell us more about that well of course
february always black history month here
at the smith center we've got a lot of
things online
okay and we're adding some programs with
their friends from the new jersey
performing arts center around social
justice
and so i'll encourage people to go to
our website and here in the next few
days
you're going to see added programs all
around social justice this is amazing
this is so incredible from
again like you said the partnership with
ccsd to get kids watching
and being able to attend those virtual
matinees we've got things for the
couples happening for valentine's day
and for black history month and
have that social justice discussion and
things like that and programming
and so also just want to bring attention
we just had a
a great performer here in las vegas just
recently passed
uh kind of tell us you know again your
thoughts well we
we miss miss mary wilson uh so much you
know she was scheduled to be back
here at myron's cabaret jazz and uh
and at this point we're gonna have to
just rely on our memories of her other
performances here at the smith center
and know that she left behind a great
legacy and part of that legacy is how
she interacted with
our local community and with the
musicians in particular
you know i was on facebook last night
and i bet you i
knew a hundred people who posted photos
with them
and mary wilson wow because she always
took the time
to reach out to local musicians
wonderful well thank you so much so
again to honor her memory and we have
all the information
to get plugged into these cultural
events and
the arts and things like that happening
here at the smith center
their website and they can get pick up
tickets to continue to support this
men's
the smith center here in las vegas so
reporting live bianca holman
8 news now yeah some really good ideas
and gosh
37 million dollars lost it's just hard
to believe all right bianca thank you
for that